[Music]
adding support for a new platform
feature in your app can be a very
repetitive process many times you will
switch back and forth between your code
and a step-by-step tutorial or
documentation especially where you're
not familiar with the API that was the
case when I was implementing support for
appellants in a sample apps back when
Android marshmallow was released Apple
Inc's is a neat feature that lets you
verify domain that is listed in your
activities intent filters from that
moment forward whenever a user clicks on
a URL containing this domain your app
will open automatically without showing
the disambiguation dialog I remember
that in order to make this API work I
had to make many small changes in
different parts of my app which is why I
was very curious when I heard about the
new app link assistance that is part of
the Android studio 2.3 release its
promise to add app link support in your
project with just a few clicks without
leaving the ID let's see how that works
out I found a perfect sample app for my
experiment under Google / search samples
on github it's a very bare-bones recipe
app the main page doesn't really do
anything but there's also a content
provider with several example recipes
set up and ready to be displayed in the
detail page implemented in recipe
activity all I need to do is open the
activity and call show recipe passing it
content URI which matches the recipe in
the content provider now imagine that
I'm also running a website for my app
and I'd like my users to be able to
share and open links to recipes in the
same way regardless of which device they
are using let's see how long it takes to
implement this using the app links
assistant you'll find the assistant
under the Tools menu and it shows up as
a panel on the right side here first
step I want to define URL mappings in my
app I will add just one to connect
recipe URLs to the detail activity I
just have to fill in my website's
hostname and what path to match I'll use
the path prefix recipe to also capture
any recipe ID after the last path
separator and I want to launch the
recipe activity the tool generates the
correct intent filter and adds it to my
manifest I can even see a preview of the
changes and check
the URL I need will get much the correct
activity step two add logic to the
activity to handle the URL I'll select
the activity that I specified in the
previous step and some code gets added
to my own create method this is just to
help you get the necessary data from the
intent but remember that it's up to you
to actually handle it in your app in my
case I want to load and show the correct
recipe for that I need the recipe ID
which is the last path part in the URL
now I'll just convert that to a URI
pointing to my content provider and pass
it on to show recipe in some cases such
as this one when the activities launch
mode is set to single top you will also
have to handle a new intent delivered to
an already running instance of the
activity I will refactor the code
I just wrote into a new method and
called that from on new intent as well
before I move on to configuring applix
on my server I just want to check that
everything I configured so far works on
the device I'll just use the aplans
tester in step 4 to launch a URL
pointing to the grilled potato salad
recipe it correctly launches my app and
shows the recipe great you might have
noticed that this immigration dialog
that popped up when I launched the URL
getting rid of it and launching directly
into the app is the last part let's
proceed with step 3
generating the digital asset links file
you'll need a few details about your app
such as the domain you're using in your
links application ID and assigning
config most of these will normally be
prefilled for you so you can just click
the generate button now you will need to
place this file under this path on a
domain that you control please note that
this is where it's the easiest to make a
mistake the path must match exactly the
well-known folder must be under the root
of the domain and the server must be
using a valid HTTPS certificate to serve
the file even if your app links are only
using HTTP for testing my app I'm just
using github pages which gives me an
easy way of hosting my asset links file
with the correct ssl certificate
let's test a sample link again it's step
four and be app launches taking me
directly into the recipe no need to
click through a dialogue this time fat
saplings fully added to a sample app in
just four steps without looking at the
documentation if you like the app links
assistance or if you have any feedback
please let us know on our social channel
thanks for watching and for more Android
to your videos click here
[Music]